danny está a la espera del regreso de
sus hijos desde ucrania las habitaciones
están intactas desde hace tres años
cuando daniela y sebastián se fueron a
estudiar ingeniería aeronáutica al país
ubicado al este de europa ahora han
emprendido el retorno huyendo de la
tierra la decisión que hemos tomado como
familia de que ellos vuelvan y que
danielle específicamente vuelva ya
estando por cumplir tres años allá en su
carrera de ingeniería de aviación es
simplemente para una tranquilidad y
obtener en ellos y recuperar en ellos
una paz mental y psicológica que debe
estar afectada danny visita a diario la
cancillería ecuatoriana en búsqueda de
información se encuentra con más padres
que desean traer a sus hijos de vuelta
para alejarlos del conflicto entre rusia
y ucrania
leonel es otro padre preocupado recibe
una llamada de su hijo ha logrado llegar
a varsovia pero las noticias no son del
todo buenas como padre el dolor es
grande pero yo le comento que mi hijo no
regresa adecuados él no va a regresar a
ecuador desde una sala de atención
improvisada la cancillería rastrea
satelitalmente los ecuatorianos e
intenta convencerlos de abordar un vuelo
humanitario con espacio para 350 con
nacionales recibimos muchísimos pedidos
de que se puedan quedar en españa o en
italia les quiero les quiero decir de
corazón que regrese en ecuador que les
pidan que les aconsejen y poder anunció
que no podrá otorgar visas para estadía
en un país europeo por ello usted va a
prefiere salvarse de la guerra y huir a
su país la comida
y
aquí están los documentos de vuelta en
casa van y se apura certificar la
nacionalidad de sus hijos para que
puedan regresar en el primer vuelo de
repatriación que enviará el gobierno
ecuatoriano quiere no regrese y
ministerio están obligados a firmar un
acuerdo de responsabilidad ante el
gobierno ecuatoriano por permanecer de
manera irregular
en la unión europea